welcome back to the show remember the
number one way to support the work we do
grab a membership join pacman.com easy
quick feels good no reason not to do it
uh we are going to hear from some folks
there are people
aching to get on the air with me today
via the david pakman show official
discord
which you can find at davidpakman.com
slash discord that's d-i-c
no i'm sorry d-i-s-c-o-r-d
uh let's start today there are just so
many people it's hard to know where to
start
let's start with mel from florida mel
from florida you're on the air
mel from florida we can hear you yeah
awesome
hi david hi so uh i was playing around
with
5 38 uh you know where you changed the
the states around on the electoral map
yeah and it looks like even without
knowing if he gets pennsylvania
wisconsin or
michigan biden's chance of winning jumps
to above
99 if he just picks up florida
yes so we were going through some of
these scenarios so what one of the big
things that happened this week is the
supreme court
decided that pennsylvania will continue
counting ballots received all the way up
until three days after
election day and there if we imagine for
a second we won't know pennsylvania
on election night there are a whole
bunch of scenarios
where if biden is able to take wisconsin
and michigan
and nothing else the election will be
determined by pennsylvania
if biden takes florida but not wisconsin
and michigan
the election will be determined by
pennsylvania but what you're
accurately pointing out is if biden
takes florida
it's unlikely that that's the only
change from 2016 i think if biden takes
florida he almost certainly gets
wisconsin and or michigan
that would make pennsylvania unlikely to
be the deciding state and you are very
very much on board which is if biden
gets florida
it's it's difficult to imagine a path
for him to lose although
flipping florida alone is not actually
enough for biden to get to 270.
right yeah that's what i was looking at
i just saw that because it's such a big
state
and it is kind of you know in it's
swingable so yeah i was wondering what
your take on that would be
yeah yeah i mean i agree so we have to
understand the math is florida alone
isn't enough
the reality is if biden wins florida he
probably at least gets either arizona
wisconsin or michigan in which case i
believe it would be enough and
pennsylvania
no longer matters
thank you yeah that was i was all i
really was like wondering
about because of course that's i'm in
that state yeah so
did you already did you vote early by
mail or what did you do
uh no i'm actually gonna vote on
election day
okay um in part because i want to make
sure that there isn't anybody
pounding people at the polls you know
right yeah and if there is if you can
safely film it and get me the video we
we will be covering that
intimate intimidation and the like oh
yeah absolutely
so all right mel thank you so much thank
you
all right mel from florida voting in
person very very
exciting stuff going on there if you
love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always struggling
to find the time check out one of my
all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video